"Wo ist die Tür zum Jenseits von Gut
und Böse und wie sieht es dort aus?"
Die Tür zum Jenseits von Gut
und Böse und wie es dort aussieht?
Die Tür ist bei Nietzsche.
Seite 67. - Und es sieht so aus,
dass alles eine Erfindung ist.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Hallo zusammen. Wir sind "Bleisch
& Bossart", Yves und ich, Barbara.
Jetzt bleibt noch das Q&A.
Heute nehmen wir uns eure Fragen vor,
die ihr uns geschickt habt.
Wir sind gespannt. Wir haben
keine Ahnung über den Inhalt.
Sicher wieder gescheite Fragen
von unserer Community.
Du glaubst ja, wir haben keins.
Gar kein Bewusstsein?
- Nein, aber du glaubst ja,
dass wir nur
so ein Synapsen-Gestöber sind.
Ich glaube, dass es weg ist.
Die Idee, dass wir ein Tropfen sind,
der wieder ins Meer fällt,
in ein kosmisches Bewusstsein,
finde ich auch schön.
Aber vermutlich ist sie falsch.
- Es hängt davon ab,
was man unter Bewusstsein versteht.
Ob der Geist irgendwo da draussen
ist, wie das David Chalmers meint,
und alles Geist ist.
- Hast du eine Intuition?
Wenn du eine Wette
abschliessen müsstest ...
Ich will keine Wette abschliessen.
Es gibt Fragen,
die können wir nicht beantworten.
Und das finde ich richtig so.
Eine sehr schöne Frage.
Getriebene Wesen.
Das weckt die Kantianerin in mir.
- Das muss nicht getrieben sein.
Emanuel Kant sagt
in "Kritik der reinen Vernunft",
dass wir von Fragen belästigt sind,
die uns der Verstand aufgibt,
die der Verstand
aber nicht beantworten kann.
Wie z.B. die erste Frage vorhin.
Das führt dazu, dass wir immer wieder
Dinge wissen und herausfinden wollen,
wir kommen aber ...
"Er kommt weiter von dem Ziel",
wie es in
"Der Mond ist aufgegangen" heisst.
Ja, das beschreibt
das Wesen des Menschen sehr gut.
Wir wollen stets wissen,
was hinter einer Grenze ist.
Und Wilhelm Busch:
"Ein jeder Wunsch, wenn er erfüllt,
kriegt augenblicklich Junge."
Das ist doch weise.
Genau. - Mit Wilhelm Busch
gewinnt man immer.
Das ist eine Frage für dich, Yves.
(Seufzend)
Da gibt es ganz viele.
Weil ich keine erhalte.
Ich würde am liebsten hören,
dass ich ein guter Mensch bin,
aber das höre ich gar nicht so oft.
Ich höre eher,
dass ich etwas gut kann,
oder dass ich sympathisch
oder unterhaltsam bin.
Aber das andere wäre mir wichtiger.
Wenn mir eine Person sagt, ich hätte
einen Unterschied für sie gemacht
und sie dafür dankbar ist,
das finde ich schon schön.
Das machst du jeden Tag für mich.
- Oh Yves!
Du bist der Unterschied.
- Ja, super.
Gleichfalls, Yves. - Jetzt müsste man
es noch ernst meinen.
Der war fies. Komm, mach weiter!
Gut.
- Gut.
Weiter.
Erkläre mal,
was Kontingenzbewältigung ist.
Du weisst es wirklich nicht, oder?
Ich glaube, die Antwort ist Ja.
Und Kontingenzbewältigung heisst:
Wir müssen uns damit anfreunden,
dass vieles im Leben Zufall ist,
und selbst mein Ich wahrscheinlich
ein Zufallsprodukt ist.
Sigmund Freud sagte, wir müssten
den Zufall für würdig erachten,
über unser Schicksal zu entscheiden.
Das können viele Menschen nicht.
Viele suchen
nach eisernen Gesetzen, Mustern,
nach einer tieferen Bedeutung.
Aber vieles ist einfach nur
Windhauch, vergänglich und zufällig.
Dem habe ich nichts hinzuzufügen.
Nächste Frage.
Eine schöne Frage.
- Ja, mega schön.
Das weiss ich von dir nicht.
Kants "Kritik der reinen Vernunft"?
Die Frage ist nach der grössten
persönlichen Veränderung.
Das war bei mir "Praktische Ethik"
von Peter Singer.
Denn ich studierte zuerst
nur im Nebenfach Philosophie
und im Hauptfach Germanistik.
In einem Seminar lasen wir dann
dieses Buch von Singer.
Und da merkte ich, dass ich nur noch
Philosophie machen möchte
und machte es zu meinem Hauptfach.
Das Buch zog mich in seinen Bann.
Vielleicht auch deswegen,
weil es viele Thesen enthielt,
die mich falsch dünkten,
ohne zu wissen, warum.
Man muss nicht einverstanden sein mit
Singer, aber man kann viel lernen.
Es hat zumindest biografisch
für mich viel geändert. Bei dir?
"Der kleine Prinz".
Es war eines der ersten Bücher,
das mir vorgelesen wurde.
Ich hörte auch die CD
oder Kassette dazu.
Auch die Musik, die ganze Welt,
die poetischen und philosophischen
Überlegungen im Buch haben mich
nachhaltig geprägt. - Schön.
Ich benötige 10 Std.
und Barbara 2 Std.
Blödsinn! Ich nehme mir 10 Std. Zeit
und du 2 Std.,
und dann gehst du in die Badewanne,
weil dir dort - wie du sagtest -
die besten Ideen kommen,
während ich arbeite.
Ich halte Fantasie, Vorstellungs-
kraft für etwas sehr Wichtiges.
Auch wenn wir uns in die Zukunft
entwerfen, stellen wir uns vor ...
Wenn wir uns fragen:
"Wie soll ich leben? Wer bin ich?"
"Wie möchte ich
in zehn Jahren sein?"
Das geschieht
über unsere Vorstellungskraft
und die Rückkoppelungsfrage
"Wie fühlt sich das an?".
Z.B.: Will ich
mit dieser Person alt werden?
Das stimmt. Mir gefällt in diesem
Zusammenhang der Begriff der Regnose.
Also nicht nur die Prognose,
wie es sein wird,
sondern die Frage
"Wie möchte ich gewesen sein?" -
das Denken im Futur II,
wie es Harald Welzer nennt.
Also dass ich
weit aus der Zukunft zurückschaue
und mir vorstelle,
wie ich dann gewesen sein möchte.
Das regt meine Fantasie mehr an
als mir lediglich vorzustellen,
wie ich mal sein möchte.
Das Denken aus der Zukunft aus
finde ich anregender und produktiver.
Das ist zu komplex für mich.
- Jetzt bin ich dran.
Ich finde,
dass Achtsamkeit nie Egoismus ist.
Vielleicht sind hier Rückzug,
Mindfulness und Meditation gemeint.
Aber selbst das ...
Achtsamkeit ist immer Selbstschutz,
im Sinne von Selbstsorge,
Selbstfürsorge.
Aber es gibt ja auch
die sog. Metta-Meditation,
die sich darauf konzentriert,
Achtsamkeit mit Fokus
auf den liebevollen Umgang
mit dem Gegenüber zu praktizieren.
Daher glaube ich,
dass das nie egoistisch ist.
Wer meditiert und das alleine macht,
um fitter, wacher
und leistungsfähiger zu sein ...
Ich glaube,
diese Person hat nicht verstanden,
was Meditation eigentlich wäre.
Super Frage.
Man kann es definitiv.
Die Frage ist, ob man es sollte.
Manchmal sollte man es wohl auch.
- Du meinst, manchmal darf man es.
Genau.
Es ist die alte Schwierigkeit,
Ambivalenzen
und Widersprüche auszuhalten.
Letztlich geht es im Leben darum,
das zu lernen.
Dass Dinge, die nicht zusammen-
passen, trotzdem zusammen passieren.
Wenn man unmittelbar jemanden
leiden sieht und sich daneben freut -
das finde ich schon eigenartig.
Es geht ja auch darum,
Anteil zu nehmen.
Aber die Welt wird nicht besser,
wenn alle in Trauer verfallen.
Man muss auch stark genug bleiben,
um die Welt verbessern zu können.
Dafür braucht es Ressourcen.
Freude kann so eine sein.
Du bist schon sehr gut, Barbara.
- Ja, super.
Danke fürs Kompliment, Yves.
Nie. Das Böse verschwindet nie.
Es ist ein Teil des Menschen.
Radikal böse nach Kant.
Es ist in unserer Freiheit angelegt,
Gutes oder Böses tun zu können.
Das Einzige,
was wir dazu sagen können:
Gute Institutionen helfen,
das Böse einzuhegen.
Und einander zu kontrollieren,
nichts Böses zu tun,
heisst Stärkung von Institutionen.
Ja, und Erziehung
macht auch sehr viel aus.
Viele Täter waren selbst mal Opfer.
Sie hatten eine Scheisskindheit
und haben
viele Traumata hinter sich.
Es perpetuiert sich natürlich.
Ist das Böse erst mal da,
ist es schwierig zu eliminieren.
Erziehung ist aber
der wirkungsvollste Hebel.
Die Tür zum Jenseits von Gut
und Böse und wie es dort aussieht?
Die Tür ist bei Nietzsche.
Seite 67. - Und es sieht so aus,
dass alles eine Erfindung ist.
Dass die Wahrheit ein stehendes Heer
von Metaphern ist,
wir letztlich immer perspekti-
vistisch auf die Welt blicken
und es nur ein Spiel von Kräften
ist, bei dem wir uns Moral einreden.
Das ist Jenseits von Gut und Böse.
- Möchtest du dahin?
Nein.
Ich auch nicht. Nietzsche eignet sich
immer super zum Zitieren.
Er war ein grossartiger Literat.
- Ein Genie!
Aber in den meisten Punkten hatte er
unrecht. - Absolut. Aber ein Genie.
Bin ich an der Reihe?
- Ja.
Wenn du das liest ... Die Texte
sind zum Teil so gut! - Ja.
Aber Zweidrittel seiner Lebenszeit
lag er halb krank im Bett.
In geistiger Umnachtung.
- Nein, der ist ja ...
Super Frage.
Barbara, sag es uns.
Ich würde die Gesellschaft
doch etwas positiver darstellen.
Es gibt moralischen Fortschritt,
und wir machten ihn auch.
Denken wir z.B. daran,
wie Kinder früher behandelt wurden -
als Arbeitskräfte genutzt,
geschlagen usw.
Oder auch Frauen.
Wir sind ein Stück weit
eine gleichere und
respektvollere Gesellschaft geworden.
Daher glaube ich
an moralischen Fortschritt.
Trotzdem
wiederholen wir gewisse Fehler.
Das hat einerseits
mit dem radikal Bösen zu tun,
worüber wir gerade sprachen.
Zudem sind wir Gewohnheitswesen
und sinnliche Wesen.
Wenn etwas ganz weit weg ist,
ist es nicht mehr Teil unserer Welt,
obwohl es passiert ist.
Aber wenn wir diese Erinnerung
nicht kultivieren, verschwindet das.
Also ein Argument
für Erinnerungskultur.
Emotional muss es noch
in uns drin sein.
Dann sind wir wach genug, und es
treibt uns an zum richtigen Handeln.
Aber wenn es emotional verblasst,
verfallen wir in alte Muster.
Danke vielmals für eure Fragen
und fürs Mitdiskutieren.
Wir freuen uns immer riesig, wenn wir
mit euch ins Gespräch kommen.
Wenn ihr weitere Fragen
oder Kommentare habt,
Gäste- oder Ideenvorschläge,
schreibt es in die Kommentarspalte
oder besucht unsere Instagramkanäle.
Vielen Dank und bis zum nächsten Mal!
Untertitelung: Dragana Sucevic
im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2022